man I wish I was cool as Juliet
Silo dwellers and non-solo dwellers we
have come to the end of season one but
fear not Apple has renewed The Show for
another season yes the Apple Smash Hit
will be returning after an absolutely
jaw-dropping finale which manages to
answer a lot of questions while
simultaneously opening up a world of
possibility in this video we'll be going
over the biggest theories Clues and
Mysteries of season one and as always
I've left timestamps below to all the
topics I'll be covering and don't worry
I haven't read the books so there won't
be any spoilers beyond episode 10. and
be sure to stick around to the end of
the video because there are some really
interesting details I found in that
mind-blowing final shot and bonus points
if you found the hidden you Howie cameo
in this episode I'll point that out too
so without further Ado it's time to
clean since episode 1 the hard drive has
been one of the biggest mysteries of the
show and in the finale it meets its
unfortunate demise or does it it's a bit
ironic that that will see this hard
drive smash just like Juliet saw her
mother's magnifying device smashed more
Curious however is that Bernard keeps
the smashed pieces and we see him fixate
on this disc this is called the rigid
disc or platter and it's where all the
data is stored the question I'm asking
myself is if this drive is so dangerous
how come he didn't have it immediately
incinerated why keep it around its
continued presence implies that this
isn't the end of the drive and that
theoretically data still might be able
to be retrieved the drive also had the
number 18 on it the same number found on
Bernard's key fob in episode 1 Allison
asks the idea what the 18 means and then
it cuts to Mayor Ruth's speech where she
says this
and six seconds
past six o'clock add all those numbers
up and you get 18. I personally think
that 18 refers to their Silo number at
the end of the episode we'll see a bunch
of these silos I counted more than 44.
it could be that hers is designated
number 18 but more on that in a bit
Bernard's key fob turns out to be a key
to this it server room when Bernard
opens the door to it check out the
reflection in his glasses there are tons
of these fluorescent lights implying
that this room is pretty massive is it
also just a coincidence that right after
Bernard accesses the server room
Juliet's vision of the Jane Carmody
video disappears this would suggest that
the server room controls these almost
holographic type images Juliet sees on
the outside we still have a unanswered
question about this drive in episode 1
Allison remarks that there's an
engraving and it reads at 501 334
library library ends up being the code
to access the drive and mayor Ruth
remarks about Library and burn and all
the books in our libraries as for the 80
and numbers it hasn't been cracked yet
one thing that wasn't seen in the
episode was if Juliet's broadcast of the
Jane Carmody video reached the screens
in the cafeteria this would surely have
huge implications in people demanding
answers if a wide swath of Silo dwellers
saw this but seeing as Sims tells
Bernard that things have gotten rather
quiet since the arrest of Juliet it
doesn't seem to be the case the finale
also leaves us with a new sheriff in
town but with some serious implications
Sims knows that Deputy Paul Billings has
the syndrome and those with the syndrome
cannot be in positions such as sheriff
yet Paul becomes the sheriff at the end
of the episode anyway all we know is
that Sims and the mayor have granted
Paul an exemption from this rule
essentially making Paul a puppet Sheriff
who has to do what they say just like
judge Meadows is a puppet judge but
there's one thing Paul hasn't disclosed
to Sims the piece of paper he ripped out
of the adventures in Georgia book found
in Juliet's apartment I wonder if like
Juliet and Holston before him he'll
continue the tradition of being a
sheriff and looking for Clues and a
great place to start asking questions
would be Danny and Patrick who he
learned were picked up and put in
custody the biggest event this episode
was Juliet being sent out to clean but
unlike the countless cleaners before her
she somehow miraculously survives but
how did she do it it all starts with
Juliet telling Martha listen to me there
are things I need to tell you okay we
never do hear what those things were but
it's enough to compel Martha to leave
her apartment for the first time in 25
years she travels 24s up to visit Carla
her ex-wife we saw a picture of her in
Martha's apartment back in episode 6.
Carla Works in Supply the part of The
Silo which collects and distributes
various supplies including the tape
that's used to seal up the cleaner suits
but there's something that's always
rubbed Martha the wrong way her tape is
way better than judicial so how come
judicial won't use her hers doesn't make
any sense
unless it does one of the last images we
see of Martha before she leaves her
apartment is her picking up a spool of
her owned tape this will then be given
to Carla who will exchange it with the
judicial's tape so when Julia is
taped up she's getting the good stuff
that's why when Juliet receives her note
from Martha it says have no fear they
are good in Supply I also just love how
Martha has brought this note in a tin of
hush puppies the same thing she brought
up with Hank in episode 5 but he ate
them all if you need anything
I'm just a 10 a hush puppies away this
type of setup and payoff extends to the
tape itself too in episode 3 The Reason
Bernard didn't want Juliet to be mayor
among other things was that she stole a
box of tape for my tea Bernard doesn't
want anyone piecing together that it's
tape is and that same tape is being
used on the cleaners and before we get
any further just a quick reminder if you
like these types of videos to like And
subscribe every little bit helps the
channel out in exchange for showing
Juliet what happened to George Juliet
must agree that she said she wanted to
go outside and wave her right to a
Judicial hearing this is why she doesn't
answer her father when he asks why she
would choose to go outside in a total
breach of protocol Bernard brings Juliet
to the Janitor's Closet where she sees
they've been watching her all along
stating we haven't had a chance there
she has shown the video of George
falling over the edge of the silo rather
than be taken into custody we'll see him
hold his heart and look straight into
the camera as he does it almost as if he
knows Juliet will one day see this now I
don't believe that George has some power
to see into the future he just thinks
Juliet will find his Clues and expose
this Silo for what it is if this were to
happen a rebellion would surely ensue
and theoretically Juliet would gain
access to the janitor closet where she'd
see this Tate George was right that
she'd one day see this video just not in
the way he intended George had to kill
himself the alternative would be
judicial torturing him until he gave up
the whereabouts of the hard drive so his
death was a sacrifice for the greater
good bonus points if you caught that it
was Douglas Trumbull who was in charge
of escorting George kinda ironic that
he'll meet the same fate as George
falling over the edge last episode we
learned that Bernard hasn't chosen a
shadow to become de facto ruler of The
Silo in fact he was second-guessing Sims
being the man for the job after Sims put
the protection of his family over that
of The Silo well it seems Bernard has
changed his mind telling Sims that he
was rash in saying that and tomorrow
they'll have a discussion about his
future I don't trust Bernard at all and
and this could all be applied
additionally I wonder what Sims and his
wife Camille have up their sleeves in
episode 9 we learned that the two of
them have quote one goal one ambition is
that to see Sims in the top spot or is
there something else at play here in
exchange for helping with the capture of
Juliet Lucas is spared from cleaning but
given 10 years labor in the mines we've
never seen the minds but with all this
talk of tunnels below The Silo and other
silos I wonder if this isn't the last
we'll see of Lucas before heading out to
clean Juliet has one last conversation
with Bernard which has some juicy pieces
of information according to Bernard
Juliet's parents were never supposed to
have children this could mean that
Hannah was deemed quote too curious just
like Allison was and her birth control
never should have been taken out Bernard
calls Juliet's birth a miracle but the
more likely scenario is that Pete
Nichols being a doctor removed the
implant himself Dr Nichols did know how
to do this as Juliet found out he was
complicit in judicial plan to deceive
families that their implants were
removed when they never actually were
also according to Bernard Hannah's
suicide was her own choice although we
can never be a hundred percent certain
that this is true considering who it's
coming from finally I want to
acknowledge this look when Juliet tells
Bernard about the massive door made of
steel at the bottom of the silo it's
such an ambiguous look that I'm not sure
if he knows about this door or doesn't
George told Juliet that he found this
door but wasn't able to get it open in
the hard drive blueprints we can see
this door is most likely connected to
this tunnel leading to who knows where
but now that we've seen multiple silos
in the outside world I think we can
assume that these silos are all
connected Juliet's last request is to be
given holston's badge I think it's kind
of endearing that she'll place it on his
dead body Juliet has finally found the
truth and things have come full circle
since Holston left the airlock her last
words are I'm not afraid for comparison
Allison's last words were I love you and
holston's sorry for all the fuss upon
entering the airlock connecting The Silo
to the outside world we'll see this
white smoke envelope Juliet now I'm
going to throw this Theory out there
because I just want to cover any
potential scenario but what if this is
the poison that slowly kills the
cleaners not the outside air the smoke
reminds me of something you'd find in a
decontamination chamber what if that
were the case why is she being
decontaminated when heading outside
that's something that should only happen
when something is coming back inside any
trace of poison would be eliminated when
the chamber is lit up after a cleaner is
sent out honestly I'm probably looking
too deep into this and the smoke is just
air pressure adjusting as we do see the
outside world and it does look like
everything is dead we'll see that Juliet
is given this piece of wool used to
clean the sensor the first entry in The
Silo book series is called wool and its
name can also be a nod to the saying
pull the wool over someone's eyes which
means deceiving someone by telling them
untruth just like The Silo dwellers are
deceived now here's where we can get
into some crazy theories how is Juliet
seeing this hologram Theory one is that
it's projected through her helmet like
some sort of augmented reality we do
hear birds chirping in her helmet which
would suggest the presence of a speaker
in there in augmented reality helmet
would also imply her helmet is being
transmitted as signal wirelessly and to
my knowledge nothing in The Silo is
Wireless so that's a bit weird Theory
too is that there is some sort of
projection from a dome-like structure in
the blueprints we can see the top of the
silos are built with these domes and you
can even see one of the blueprints
labeled the Dome structural dock spec
7.1 Juliet makes it over the ridge where
the Dome would have ended so this theory
is tough to confirm what we do know is
that this hologram is most likely
controlled by Bernard since after he
goes into the server room Juliet's Jane
Carmody video is cut off and before
going into that room Bernard tells Sims
she knows and Sims is like knows what
which would suggest that even Sims
doesn't know what's going on the
Revelation that there are multiple silos
really opens up the world to a lot of
possibilities are there other Bernard
type characters in The Other silos who
communicate with one another or is their
Silo completely cut off from the rest
and these other silos have they formed
different types of societies and
hierarchies and are there some silos
that have completely Fallen apart this
all leads to where does Juliet go from
here to me there are two options one of
the neighboring silos or this destroyed
City in the background I think she'll
first try one of these neighboring silos
if they have working sensors she could
try making contact with him if they're
still alive and if this silos are indeed
connected by these secret underground
tunnels then this could be her ticket to
getting back and saving everyone she
loves now I want you to pay close
attention to this Silo directly across
from Juliet's we can see it has the
little sensor structure but there's no
indentation where the airlock door
should be other silos have this but not
this one my guess is that this is a dead
Silo no one has been out of it for years
and dust has collected over the entrance
making it impossible to see how creepy
would it be if in season 2 we get to see
a silo just filled with skeletons from
some sort of catastrophic failure the
other possibility is this city in the
background it looks absolutely desolate
and way too far but it's an option in my
past videos I've theorized we could be
in or around Atlanta Georgia largely due
in part to the adventures in Georgia
book The fact the Stars confirm were
somewhere in the Northern Hemisphere and
these documents called FL requisitions
could this mean that as these silos were
being built supplies were coming in from
Florida which just so happens to
neighbor Georgia I could also see this
being Rally or Charlotte North Carolina
since that's where writer Hugh Howie is
from speaking of which bonus points if
you caught him as an extra during the
cleaning scene excellent work you no
notes there's also the question of what
exactly happened to this world the
presence of multiple silos would suggest
Humanity knew something apocalyptic was
going to happen since a project of this
size would take decades to complete so
my guess is this wasn't a spontaneous
nuclear attack rather something slow
building like climate change now when
Juliet makes it over the silos Ridge
there are a ton of interesting details
in the Far Far background we can make
out this almost wall-like structure
surrounding the perimeter of the silos
every half kilometer or so accompanied
by tall man-made structures that look
like they could be Highway lights
outposts or part of a bigger structure
additionally I counted at least 44 silos
from the end shot and that's not even
including any silos that could be behind
the camera most of the silos also appear
to have a divot we can see one here here
and here this was a conscious decision
by the VFX company to add these in so
they've got to serve some sort of
purpose is it something left over from
construction well I've thoroughly
enjoyed breaking down this series with
you now it's time for you to take over I
want to hear your thoughts and theories
in the comments below and for season 2
should I read the books or should I
continue with these spoiler-free reviews
let me know thanks for watching please
be sure to like And subscribe and film
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at pinkstory YT
until next time remember shut your eyes
all of you try your eyes say your eyes
turn around
foreign